so good
starwars the last July for the pg-13
everybody stopped
action episode eight gosh the first film
didn't even have a number
Ryan has written a story that's
unexpected but right
[Music]
some of the stuff that happens people
gonna be not oh my god
even though I think I know it all they
throw things at me story wise I never
could have imagined and even though
everybody knows it's the second in a
trilogy it feels like its own thing
go
Star Wars is so cool because there's all
these creatures probably amazing visual
effects
like all the characters are also so
complex
Ryan nece the workers wiki South
particular new director Kali vicious
Lana will keys out
it feels like the storylines becoming
more established
we're really getting to know these new
characters also with the characters that
we know and love
their lives change
everything is being shifted in the
opposite way to what the audience
expected after 7:00
Brian's made Star Wars fresh in you
I'm hoping it'll be a little shocking
but I'm hoping it'll feel real and
honest
the comments Asian story of good against
evil
hold in the most fascinating way but it
has a real spirit two objective to it
it's about family and that's what's so
powerful about it
you